way we can get into other things dude
there's a lot i want to
talk to you about can i start the
beginning with you guys when did you
guys meet
what's your timeline together uh first
time that we met i'm gonna guess it was
um probably like in the filming of
was it jackass number two that you came
into the scene was it it was two is when
i came to the scene but remember the
gumball rally was that before yeah but i
wasn't on your gun ball rally i don't
think when we went out we destroyed that
car
i feel like that was the first night we
really
hit it off
okay i don't know which came first but
that was a jackass number two situation
yeah so so i guess the filming of were
you not on viva la bam yeah you weren't
there yeah you were totally yeah
all right well i think that the first
time i remember
would have been uh like the day when
they brought like a snow blower into
like april's house and it was like ski
down the stairs that's that that you're
right that was the first initial meeting
and dude it's your [ __ ] fault dude
that i got that uh awful baby tattoo
because i remember the [ __ ] ball
because that day when they filled the
house with snow and you went skiing down
the stairs and flew through the screen
door it was that same day and i think it
was the first day that we met when i saw
your your tattoo of two
male rollerblades the
rollerbladers like having missionary
gay sex
and it was i was just like dude that is
the most aggressive i remember yeah like
hilarious tattoo
and then like you were
i was like i gotta one-up that
and i remember when that was like my
motivation
and you did
you did you did it and then people were
like he did
like stephen we love you we're your fan
but
yeah
yeah
does that mean your rollerblader sex
tattoo looks so classy
i just won by default
yeah story of my life dude
yeah
and um
well i was so stoked because you were
like you were writing a book at the time
you're like i'm gonna use that for the
cover of my book oh i don't know that i
was writing a book you had some kind of
book i was always working on a book but
um but it was never like a real serious
thing until after i got sober but
nonetheless like you were [ __ ]
steps and eons ahead of me as far as
like the fame with jackass so i was just
taking it vicariously through you
wanting my tattoo on your book like i'll
[ __ ] ride that coattail let's do it
yeah dude yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude